vous savez en quoi consiste mon boulot
je suis aux acquisitions
je lève les yeux et je récupère tout ce
qui tombe du ciel
y'a quoi dans le vaisseau
[Musique]
parlez moi de la mission avez vous vu
quoi que ce soit d'inhabituel
ça c'est au-dessus de nos fonctions
alors j'ai gagné une sucette j'ai bien
compris il s'est passé un truc au
mexique et il faut pas de témoins
gênants
on doit savoir si vous et vos hommes
représentait un danger
on est des rangers et baxley si la
chatte de ta mère est un jeu vidéo je te
parie que sa classe et tout public pour
présenter un danger
ça serait pas un petit peu l'idée
oui
[Musique]
et prédateurs passent pas leur journée à
se faire des chapeaux avec nos il
colonise l'espace mais ce n'est pas ce
qui se profile à l'horizon
est-ce que je dois m'inquiéter peut-être
je crois que vous savez ce qu'il y à
bord les prédateurs ultime
on va peut-être crever
mais c'est pas encore fait
alors à bientôt espèce d'enfoiré